later this month it will be one year
since the last american forces left
afghanistan ending a 20-year presence in
the country it was the longest war in
u.s history the government collapsed
when the taliban swept to power within
days mts taeyab is in kabul the capital
for a look at what has happened in the
last 12 months
good morning well a series of deadly
attacks over the past month is a massive
concern considering the relative peace
that followed the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan and is perhaps a sign that
the taliban's grip on this country isn't
as tight as it seems
the horrifying aftermath of a suicide
bombing at a kabul mosque at least two
dozen were killed in the deadly attack
including the imam who was the apparent
target
is one of the survivors
i was attending evening prayer when the
explosion happened he says it was very
powerful and happened right inside the
mosque
as mourners buried loved ones the u.n
says the bombing is the latest in a
series of attacks which have killed and
injured more than 250 people in recent
weeks
the highest monthly number of civilian
casualties since the taliban's takeover
one year ago
the surge in violence comes as the
taliban celebrated the one-year
anniversary of its takeover of
afghanistan hundreds of heavily armed
olives and supporters filled this square
in central kabul not far from the now
abandoned u.s embassy
chanting god is great as taliban leaders
continue to transform afghanistan by
stripping women of basic rights barring
most high school-aged girls from
education and brutally cracking down on
any form of dissent despite the fact the
nation's economy has collapsed and is in
the grips of what the u.n is calling the
world's worst humanitarian disaster
at the rally we met abdullah sahami are
you happy with the taliban's leadership
no i'm not happy because
the economic problem is very
bad in afghanistan and also the
education is not
good
you know that the girl schools are
closed
so as the taliban celebrates one year on
the lives of ordinary afghans are
increasingly a misery
now no group has yet claimed
responsibility for the deadly mosque
attack but it follows a pattern that
we've seen with the afghan affiliate of
isis known as isis k
and the concern is is that the group
is only getting stronger
dana
all right mts thank you